so at the last company I was working at
I was helping set up our user testing
program and one of the products that we
were testing for was a desktop control
software as it helped you use your
desktop and we realized very early on
that obviously we're not going to be in
the room when our user starts to use the
software we're not going to be able to
give them instructions we're not gonna
be able to tell them how to use it so we
were also ending or we also had to use
some machine learning algorithms to help
detect what the user intended to do and
have the software respond appropriately
and we realized that the the machine
learning algorithms were very finely
tuned at first to us you know we would
say we would do a certain thing and it
would get it every single time and we
would give it to somebody else and they
would inevitably do something different
and it wouldn't work at all right so
what we ended up doing is creating a
tutorial video and this was a argue is
that this is a prototype of the actual
video that would ship with the product
right to explain to a customer or a user
how to use it and we ended up user
testing those in parallel so we're going
to bring a user into our user testing
lab we would sit them down say we're
going to show you a video we're going to
then give you a set of tasks with the
software and see how well you do you
know and then all the you know we're not
testing you were destined software all
that right and sit then we would sit
them down and we would shut up the
examiner where the tester would shut up
would roll a video and be very careful
not to actually put their hands out or
show them you know how to use the
software and then we would test them and
so by optimizing those in parallel we
ended up getting much much better
performance and a much better prediction
of the eventual users performance than
we would have if we had demonstrated how
to do these because we know how to
trigger the machine learning algorithms
right perfect thank you